OF MORE RESIGNATIONS.
LET ME BACK UP AND TELL YOU WHAT
HAPPENED.
THE SITE POSTED A SHOCKING STORY
ABOUT A MARRIED MEDIA EXECUTIVE
RELATED TO A FORMER OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS.
IT TALKS AND HOW HE WAS
ATTEMPTING TO HIRE A GAY ESCORT
WHO APPARENTLY BLACKMAILED HIM.
IT WENT ONLINE AND THE NEGATIVE
FEAT FEEDBACK, CRITICS USING
VILE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SHOW THE
POST.
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE.
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THE
REACTION.
THE NEXT DAY NICK DENTON CHOSE
TO DELETE IT. THE FOUNDER AND
CEO OF GAWKER MEDIA.
WELCOME BACK TO THE SHOW.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> THIS BLOG POST WENT UP ON
THURSDAY NIGHT.
DID YOU KNOW ABOUT IT?
>> I KNEW ABOUT IT.
I KNEW THE TEAM WAS WORKING ON
THE STORY.
>> HOW COULD YOU HAVE NOT
INSISTED ON READING IT BEFORE IT
WAS PUBLISHED ON YOUR WESTBOUND
SITE?
>> I HAVE TO SAY I THOUGHT IT
WOULD TAKE MORE TIME TO GO UP ON
A FRIDAY.
>> YOU THOUGHT YOU'D HAVE TIME
TO READ IT, THOUGHT YOU WOULD BE
INVOLVED?
>> I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE MORE
TIME FOR THE EDITORIAL TEAM TO
DISCUSS IT BEFORE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE STORY.
I DIDN'T SEE THE POINT OF THE
STORY AS IT WAS DESCRIBED TO ME.
I MADE THAT CLEAR, AND WHEN I
SAW THE STORY LATER ON, IT WAS
VERY, VERY CLEAR, NOT JUST FROM
THE UNIVERSAL REACTION WHICH WAS
CONDEMNATION FROM OUR PEERS, BUT
ANYBODY WITH ANY KIND OF
HUMANITY, COULD SEE THIS WAS NOT
A STORY WORTH DOING.
>> YOU DECIDED TO TAKE IT DOWN.
THERE ARE REPORTS THERE WAS A
VOTE AMONG YOUR BUSINESS LEAD RS
AND MOST OF THEM SUPPORTED YOU.
WHY WAS IT PUT UP TO A VOTE?
>> THIS WAS MY DECISION, I
ORDERED THE POST TAKEN DOWN.
>> IT WASN'T A VOTE?
>> THE COLLEAGUES, MY EXECUTIVES
SUPPORTED ME IN MY DECISION, BUT
IT WAS MY DECISION.
I AM THE FOUNDER OF THE COMPANY.
I WAS THE EDITOR OF GAWKER.COM.
I AM THE GUARDIAN OF THE
EDITORIAL ETHOS OF THE COMPANY.
THIS IS COUNTER TO WHAT I WANT
US TO BE DOING.
THEREFORE, I HAD IT TAKEN DOWN.
>> GAWKER SORT OF HAS THIS
REPUTATION AS BEING A PLACE
WHERE ANYTHING GOES.
IF IT'S TRUE, YOU PUBLISH IT.
HERE IS PART OF THE INTERVIEW
ABOUT HULK HOGAN.
>> KNOWING WHAT YOU KNOW NOW,
KNOWING ALL THE LEGAL COSTS
ALREADY, WOULD YOU HAVE STILL
PUBLISHED THE VIDEO?
>> I'M GLAD THE DECISIONS THAT
TAKEN ON PUBLISHING, TAKEN AT
THE TIME AND I'M GLAD THAT WE
ONLY REALLY LOOK AT WHETHER THE
STORY IS BOTH TRUE AND
INTERESTING.
THIS STORY WAS TRUE AND
INTERESTING AND WE'D ABSOLUTELY
PUBLISH IT AGAIN IN A HEARTBEAT.
>> THIS WAS A SEX TAPE INVOLVING
HULK HOGAN, NOW HE'S SUING.
WE CAN GET INTO THE LAWSUIT.
WHAT YOU SAID IS WHAT WE LOOK AT
IS WHETHER THE STORY IS TRUE AND
INTERESTING.
IS THAT STILL TRUE?
>> I THINK THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN TONY CRAGGS, THE
EXECUTIVE EDITOR WHO RESIGNED ON
PRINCIPLE IN THIS MATTER, THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HIM AND ME,
FOR TOMMY AND SOME OF THE MORE
HARD LINE EDITORIAL STAFF, TRUTH
ITSELF IS THE ONLY NECESSARY
DEFENSE, AND THE BELIEF IS THAT
NOTHING SHOULD EVER BE TAKEN
DOWN IF IT IS TRUE.
AS I SAID IN THAT QUOTE, I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S NOT -- IT'S
NECESSARY FOR SOMETHING MORE
THAN JUST SIMPLY TRUTH TO BE
OPERATIVE IN A STORY AND TRUTH
AND THE WILL NOT
TOUCH, NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE BAD
STORIES, BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE
AFRAID OF PERSECUTION.
WE WOULD OUT A PUBLIC FIGURE --
I PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN STORIES ABOUT TIM COOK, THE
CEO OF APPLE.
>> THAT WAS BEFORE HE SPOKE
PUBLICLY ABOUT BEING GAY.
>> CORRECT.
TWO YEARS BEFORE.
AND STORIES ABOUT ANDERSON
COOPER.
>> AGAIN BEFORE HE SPOKE
PUBLICLY ABOUT IT.
YOU'RE OKAY WITH PUBLISHING
THOSE KIND OF STORIES.
>> SOMEONE WHO IS A PUBLIC
FIGURE, WHO TALKS ABOUT THEIR
PERSONAL LIFE, INTERVIEWED BY
JOURNALISTS.
THEY DON'T GET TO SAY, OH, YOU
CAN'T ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT MY
PERSONAL LIFE.
YOU CAN'T ASK THIS PARTICULAR
QUESTION